É mito que os médicos indicam uma
pequena dose de vinho para benefícios à
saúde. Pois é, pessoal. Sabe aquela taça
de vinho que muita gente toma no jantar
achando que está fazendo bem pro
coração? Pois é, é bem polêmico isso
daí. E olha, acabei de revisitar os
estudos mais recentes, incluindo uma
publicação fresquinha de dezembro de
2024 no European Heart Journal e a nova
posição da American Heart Association
2025. Eu vou contar para vocês o que a
ciência está dizendo sobre isso. Vamos
começar pelo famoso paradoxo francês. Lá
nos anos 90, os pesquisadores ficaram
intrigados. Como é que os franceses que
comem tanta manteiga, tanto queijo,
tanta gordura saturada, que eu acho que
não faz mal, mas essa ideia deles, tem
menos infarto que os americanos. A
primeira explicação que surgiu foi deve
ser o vinho tinto. E assim nasceu toda
uma indústria de suplementação
resveratrol e uma justificativa
científica para Happy Hour. Mas calma lá
que a história pode não ser bem assim. O
que os estudos mais recentes estão
mostrando é fascinante. Em 2023, o
Medscape publicou sobre Wine Flor Study,
que analisou 42 homens com doença
coronariana e descobriu que o vinho
tinto modifica microbiota intestinal de
uma forma interessante. Mas o bacana
mesmo veio em dezembro de 24 com o
estudo Predmed publicado no European
Heart Journal. Os pesquisadores da
Universidade de Barcelona fizeram algo
genial. Ao invés de confiar no que as
pessoas diziam beber, eles mediram o
ácido tartárico na urina. E sabe o que
que é isso? É uma substância que só vem
da uva. Então não tem como mentir pro
exame de urina. E o resultado foi
impressionante. Quem bebia entre meia
taça e uma taça por dia teve uma redução
de 50% no risco cardiovascular. Isso é
mais do que muitos remédios conseguem.
Mas antes que você saia correndo paraa
Dega, deixa eu contar o resto da
história. Esse benefício só apareceu em
pessoas que já seguiam a dieta
mediterrânea e tinham um alto risco
cardiovascular. E mais, quem bebia mais
de uma taça por dia perdeu completamente
a proteção. Agora, o que que tem no
vinho que poderia fazer bem? Os
polifenóis, principalmente são aquelas
substâncias antioxidantes que dão cor ao
vinho tinto. O resveratrol é o mais
famoso deles, mas tem também as
prosianidinas, os ácidos
hidroxicinâmicos,
nomes complicados, eu sei, mas pensa
assim, são compostos que combatem
inflamação nas artérias. O estudo
mostrou que o vinho reduz moléculas
inflamatórias, como o caso do VCAN1 e o
Ian1. em português, claro, diminui a
inflamação que entope as artérias, mas
aí que vem o plot twist da história. Em
junho de 2025, o American Heart
Association soltou uma nova declaração
científica bem mais cautelosa. Eles
analisaram tudo com novas metodologias,
incluindo estudos de randomização
mendeliana, que é um tipo de experimento
genético natural. E a conclusão foi
continua desconhecido, desconhecido, se
beber faz parte de um estilo de vida
saudável. E tem mais, a Organização
Mundial de Saúde é ainda mais radical.
Eles dizem que não existe nível seguro
de consumo de álcool. Seria zero ou
nada, nem uma gotinha. Por quê? Porque
álcool seria carcinogênico, aumentaria o
risco de câncer de boca, de esôfago, de
fígado, de mama. E a lista é grande. E
olha que interessante, muitos estudos
que mostravam benefício do vinho tinham
um problema metodológico. Os abstêmios
incluíam ex-bebedores que pararam por
problemas de saúde. É como comparar quem
corre praia com quem está no hospital.
Óbvio que o corredor vai parecer mais
saudável, mas não é a corrida que fez a
diferença. Entende? Outro detalhe
importante, quem bebe vinho
moderadamente, geralmente tem outros
hábitos saudáveis, come melhor, faz mais
exercício, tem melhor acesso à saúde.
Então fica difícil separar o que que é
feito do vinho, o que que é feito do
estilo de vida. Os pesquisadores chamam
isso de fatores de confusão
e ainda tem grupos que nem deveriam
pensar em beber, obviamente, gestantes,
pessoa com histórico de alcoolismo na
família, quem tem doença no fígado,
doença hepática, arritmia cardíaca, quem
toma certos medicamentos, a lista é
longa. E mesmo para quem pode beber,
passar de uma taça por dia já era, não
tem evidência de benefício e ainda pode
ganhar risco. Agora, deixa eu te contar
uma coisa que ninguém fala. Você
consegue todos os polifenóis benéficos
comendo uva, bebendo mosto de uva
integral, comendo frutas vermelhas, sem
álcool, sem risco de dependência e sem
ressaca. Faz sentido, né? Então,
voltando à pergunta inicial. É mito que
médicos indicam vinho paraa saúde. Olha,
não é exatamente um mito, mas também não
é uma verdade absoluta. É muito
contraditório. A maioria dos médicos
hoje não recomendam começar a beber por
saúde. O consenso atual é: o vinho pode
fazer parte sim estilo de vida saudável,
mas não é necessário e nem indispensável
e definitivamente não substitui
exercício, alimentação equilibrada,
controle do estresse sono adequado.
Esses sim são os verdadeiros heróis da
saúde cardiovascular.